i've really been trying to understand
the underlying psychology of
postmodernism and its relationship with
neo-marxism and then
the
spread of that into the universities and
the effect on the culture and what i
would like to start with is
a description of your understanding of
that because i like i've presented to
the people who are listening to me my
understanding of it i interviewed
stephen hicks recently and he wrote an
interesting book called explaining
post-modernism which i liked quite a bit
it's been criticized for being too
right-wing although i don't think he's
right-wing at all i i think maybe you
could characterize him as as
middle-of-the-road conservative but i
would say he's more like a classic
liberal
but i'm really curious about your views
about
well well what what post-modernism is
first of all i know you've you've
identified it with the with the general
tricksters derrida and laka and foucault
and foucault in particular you've talked
about but i'd like to know what you
think about post-modernism and also why
you think it's been so attractive to
people
well my explanation is that there is no
authentic
1960s point of view in any of the elite
universities but rather the the most
liberated minds of my generation of the
1960s did not go on to graduate school i
witnessed this with my own eyes i saw
genuine marxists okay at my college
which was the state university of new
york at binghamton upstate new york
harper college which had a huge cohort
of very radical downstate new york jews
okay who in fact the harper used to be
called berkeley east so i saw genuine
passionate marxist with my own eyes
they were not word choppers they were
not snide postmodernists right they were
in your face aggressive they used the
language of the people they had a
populist and energy okay they dressed
working class they were
non-materialistic these are people who
lived by their own convictions they were
against the graduate schools and when i
when i
uh just went on to graduate school and
it became known that i was going to go
to yale i was confronted by a leader of
the radicals on campus
in broad daylight in front of everyone
who denounced me for he said
grad school is not where it's happening
you don't you don't do that
if you have to go to graduate school you
should go to buffalo now i had applied
to the students to suny buffalo because
the great leftist critic leslie fiedler
was there who had a huge impact on me
he's part he created created identity
politics but without its present
distortions right uh and norman holland
the psychoanalytic critic was there i
would have been very happy to have gone
on to buffalo but i needed the library
yale so i continued on to yeah there
were no radicals in
in the graduate schools right from 1968
to 72 when i was there
only one radical todd gitlin okay went
on to have a career success okay the the
actual radicals of the 1960s they either
went off dropped out of college and went
off to create communes right or they
were taking acid and destroyed their
brains now i i have also written about
that the destruction of the of the minds
okay of the most talented members of my
generation through lsd it was going on
all around me right
so what's what's happened is the actual
legacy of the 60s got truncated the idea
that these post-structuralists and
post-modernists are heirs of the 1960s
revolution is an absolute croc okay what
they represent as foucault shows shows
foucault said okay that the biggest
influence on on his thinking was samuel
beckett's waiting for godot okay which
was a post-world war ii
play
written in paris that was about the
disillusionment and nihilism experienced
after hitler went through occupied
france right and all of europe was in
ruins it had nothing to do the what's in
waiting for godot has nothing to do with
the authentic legacy of the 1960s which
was about genuine multiculturalism a
movement toward india toward hinduism a
transformation of consciousness through
psychedelics which i did not take but
which identify with totally through the
music etc right it was a turn toward the
body it was a turn towards sensory
experience okay not this this word
chopping thing and it's like cynical
removal from actual experience right
that french import okay came in okay to
the graduate schools it did not affect
any genuine 1960s person the real 1960s
revolution was about young it was about
a way of seeing the cosmos in
mythological terms right the jungian
contribution went on into the new age
movement of of the 1970s aside from the
universities right so who took over the
universities were these careerists okay
i saw them with my own eyes i saw what
happened i saw i was at yale when
derrida was being shipped over okay to
to address the uh you know the students
the grad students and and the faculty
and i and i said to a fellow student
after hearing one of these guys speak
it wasn't daradai it was it wasn't
another one of the theorists i said they
are like high priests murmuring to each
other all right this this was an elitist
form from the start okay it was not
progressive it was not revolutionary it
was reactionary it was a desperate
attempt to hold on to what had happened
before the 1960s century revolution
this postmodernist thing okay this
trashing okay of of the text this this
this encouragement okay of a superior
and destructive attitude toward the work
of art we're going through it okay
primly with red pen in hand finding all
the evidence of sexism check racism
check homophobia check that is not the
empathic emotional okay sensory based
okay a revolution of the 1960s right i
am sick and tired of these people
claiming any kind of mantle from the
1960s they're frogs these people are
what happened in the 1970s was a
collapse of the job market in in academe
right all of a sudden jobs were scarce
and this thing was there the new and
improved and shiny thing okay to be a
theorist okay people seized on it okay
it was institutionalized right and i
it's an enormous betrayal of the 1960s
okay so that you you touched on this
idea of the destruction of the work of
art
you know and and one of the things i
really liked about reading nietzsche was
his discussion of resontimal right of
resentment and
and it seems to me that a tremendous
amount of the mode of power that drives
the postmodernist let's call it it's not
a revolution
transformation seems to me to be driven
by resentment about virtually anything
that has any
well what would you say any merit of
competence or aesthetic quality
and i don't know if that's it seems to
me that that's partly rooted in the
academics disdain for the business world
which i think is driven by their
relative economic inequality because
most people who are as intelligent as
academics are from a pure iq point of
view make more money in the private
sphere and so i think that drives some
of it but there also seems to be this
there's a destruction an aim for
destruction of the of the aesthetic
quality of the of the literary or
artistic work it's reduction to nothing
but some kind of power game and then
surrounding that the reduction of
everything to something that
approximates a power game which which i
can't help but identifying with with
jealousy and resentment as a as a
fundamental motivator does that seem
reasonable to you these professors okay
who allege that art is nothing but an
ideological movement by one
elite okay
against the
ag against another group right these
people are philistines okay they're
philistines they're middle brow
hopelessly middle brow okay they they
have no sense of beauty they have no
sense of the aesthetic now marxism does
indeed assert this okay marxism tries to
reconfigure the universe in terms of
materialism it sees it it does not
recognize any kind of spiritual
dimension now i'm an atheist but i see
the great world religions as enormous
works of of art okay as the as the is
the best way to understand the universe
and man's place in it i find them
enormously moving they're they're
they're like enormous poems right
and what i have called for the true
revolution okay would have been okay to
make the core curriculum of world
education the world okay the great
religions of the world i feel that is
the only way to achieve understanding
and it's also a way to to um to present
the aesthetic okay because i feel that
that that the real 60s vision was about
exaltation elevation cosmic
consciousness right all right all of
these things they were rejected okay by
these by these
midgets okay intellectual midgets who
seized on to le con derida and foucault
right it's an and i i my career has been
in the art school so
my entire career beginning at bennington
college
so i i represent a challenge for this
from the perspective of art okay it is
an absolute nonsense okay as
post-structuralism maintains that
reality is mediated by language by words
everything that we can know including
gender is absolutely madness because i
i'm teaching students whose majors are
ceramics okay or dance okay who are
jazz musicians who understand reality in
terms of the body sensory activation so
now
see what happened was something was
going on in the art world as well i
identify with andy warhol in pop art
okay that was what was going on during
my years in college everything about
andy warhol was like wow admiration wow
what happened immediately after that in
the arts 1970s okay was this collapse
into a snide sort of post-modernism also
this happened in the art world right
right and it was an utter
misunderstanding okay of culture it
seems to me by that movement in in the
art world that is uh oppositional art in
my view is dead okay it's been and this
and what postmodernism is isn't it a
pathetic attempt to continue the old
heroism of the avant-garde the
avant-garde was genuinely heroic from
the early 19th century okay where we're
talking about you know whether cooper
bay the realists you know we're talking
about monet and the impressions people
who are genuinely suffered for their
radical ideas and their innovations and
so on right going right down to
to picasso and down to uh to jackson
pollock who like was who truly suffered
okay for his art it was only after his
death okay that suddenly the market was
created for abstract art
pop art killed the avant-garde the idea
that the avant-garde continues is an
absolute delusion of the contemporary
art world which feels that it must
attack attack attack challenge okay the
the the simplistic beliefs of the of the
hoi polloi okay somehow the art what
excuse me okay from the moment okay andy
warhol went through and embraced the
popular media in embrac instead of
having the opposition to it the serious
artists that had okay that was the end
of oppositional art okay so we have been
going on now for 50 years the
post-modernism and academies
hand-in-hand with with the stupidity and
infantilism that masquerades as you know
as as important art at galleries
everywhere this incredible incredible
you know it's mechanism of contemporary
art you're pushing things that are that
are so hopelessly derivative
and with this idea that once again that
the art world sometimes a superior view
of reality
authentic leftism is populist okay it is
based in working-class style
working-class language working-class
direct emotion a
an openness and wrestling speech okay
not this fancy contorted jargon of the
pseudo leftists of academe who are frogs
these people these people who managed to
manage to rise to the top at
berkeley at harvard and princeton okay
the idea of these people are radical
they are career people they're corporate
types okay who like who succeeded in and
they love the institutional context they
know how to manipulate the bureaucracy
which is totally invaded and usurped
okay the you know the academia
everywhere okay these people are company
players they could have done well in any
any field okay they love to sit in
endless committees they love
bureaucratic regulation and so on
there's not one what not one leftist
okay an american academe raised his or
her voice against obscene
growth of tuition costs which have
bankrupted a whole generation of young
people not not one voice okay to
challenge that that invasion by the
bureaucrats okay absolute fascist
bureaucrats okay with whoever they're
like a they're cancerous okay there's so
many of them they've the faculty have
completely lost any power in american
academy okay it's a it's a scandal what
has happened okay and they deserve the
present servitude that they're in right
now okay because they never protested
my when my first job at bennington
college 1976 i was there when there was
an uprising by the faculty against
encroachment by the board of trustees
and the president okay and it was a huge
thing it was it was it was reported on
the new york times and so on and we and
we pushed that president out okay and
and there's not been a single uprising
of that kind against against
encroachment by the trustees and by the
administrations and all these decades
okay passive slaves slaves they deserve
their slavery
yeah i couldn't agree more i i've
thought the same thing about university
professors for a long time is that they
get exactly what they deserve because
they never stand up and say no
and the fact that in the united states
it's not quite as bad in canada i
wouldn't say but the fact that the
students have been essentially handed a
bill of indentured servitude here for
their student loans is absolutely beyond
comprehension you know it seems to me
that the bureaucracy has basically
conspired to determine how to pick the
pockets of the students future earnings
right and they do that by offering them
an extended adolescence with no quality
control something like that so it's a
real bargain with the devil and a total
abandonment of any kind of education
actually in history and culture all
right there's like it's gone along with
it that is the the transformation into a
cafeteria kind of a menu okay we can
pick this course or that course or this
course without any kind of guidance from
the university about a central core
curriculum that teaches you history and
chronology and introduces you to the
basics right because because oh we have
because our professors are such prima
donnas they can only teach in their
little areas so we have this total
fragmentation okay the the great art
history survey courses are being
abandoned steadily because why because
graduate students are not trained to see
the great narratives or the network
because we are taught now that
narratives are false okay so that's
another issue that i'd like to bring up
because one of the things i cannot
figure out is the alliance between the
post-modernists and the neo-marxists i
can't understand the causal relationship
there because
tell me if you disagree with this okay
because um i'm a psychologist not a
sociologist and so i'm dabbling in
things that are outside of my field of
expertise and there is some danger in
that but the sen the central
postmodernist claim seems to me that
because there's a near infinite number
of ways to interpret a complex set of
phenomena which which actually happens
to be the case that you can't make a
case that any of those modes of
interpretation are canonical and so if
they're not canonical
if that and if that canonical element
isn't based in some kind of reality then
it serves some other master and so the
master that it hypothetically serves for
the postmodernists is nothing but power
because that seems to be everything that
they believe in they don't believe in
competence they don't believe in
authority they don't seem to believe in
an objective world because everything is
language mediated so it's an
extraordinarily cynical
perspective that that because there's an
infinite number of interpretations none
of them are canonical you can attribute
it everything to power and dominance
okay so that does that seem like a
reasonable summary of the yes exactly
okay it's a radical relativism now but
the strange thing is despite okay and so
what goes along with that is the
demolition of grand narratives and so
that would be associated for example
with the rejection of thinkers like jung
and eric neumann because of course
they're foundational thinkers um in
relationship to the idea that there are
embodied grand narratives that's never
touched but then despite the fact that
the grand narrative is rejected there's
a neo-marxism that's tightly tightly
allied with postmodernism that also
seems to shade into this strange
identity politics and i don't
two things i don't understand the causal
relationship there like the the
skeptical part of me thinks that
postmodernism was a was an intellectual
it's intellectual camouflage for the
continuation of the kind of pathological
marxism that produced the soviet union
and it has no independent existence as
an intellectual field whatsoever but
i still can't understand how the
postmodernists can make the no grand
narrative claim
but then
immerse themselves in this grand
narrative
without anyone pointing out the evident
contradictions like i don't understand
that so what do you think about that
well i can only speak about literary you
know professors really and they seem to
me almost universally in the u.s to be
very naive they know they seem to know
nothing about actual history political
science or economic so it is simply an
attitude they have an attitude
marxism becomes simply a badge by which
they telegraph their um their solidarity
with a working class that they have
nothing to do with right i mean
and generally nothing but contempt yes
and the thing is that the the the campus
leftists are almost notoriously for
their uh for their rather snobbish
treatment of staff and they don't they
don't have any rapport with the actual
working-class members of the um you know
of the infrastructure the janitor the
janitors and you know and even even the
secretaries there's a kind of high and
mighty uh aristocracy you know about
there these are just these are people
who um who have wandered into the
english department right and are were
products of a time when um
during the the new criticism
when history was history and psychology
had been excluded right
my ambition okay was i i love the new
criticism okay as as a style of textual
analysis right and and the new criticism
had multiple interpretations okay that
were possible okay and they were
encouraged in fact one of the one of the
great projects was made in mac's series
20th century reviews where you had at
least the books i adored them in college
it was about jane austen or about you
know
emily bronte or about um wordsworth and
they were collections of alternate views
of the same thing the idea that there
were no alternate views and there was no
relativistic situational kind of an
interpretive approach it's nonsense okay
but the point was we needed to restore
history to literary literary study okay
and we needed to add psychology to it
because it was there was great animus
against freud and when i arrived in in
graduate school in fact i actually went
into the director of graduate studies
and protested the way freud and freudian
were used as as negative terms okay in a
sneering way by the very wasp professors
right so we needed to and actually it
seemed like we were moving there okay in
the early 1970s was a great period of
psychobiography about great about
political figures okay
and so i thought it's happening this
year and all of a sudden it all got
short-circuited by this arrival you know
of post-structuralism and post-modernism
in the in the in the 1970s right um so i
i i i feel i'm an old historicist okay
not a new historian so i mean i think
new stories it was an absolute scam
right and it's like it's just a way it's
like tweezers you're like just you pick
a little bit of this a little bit of
that a little bit of that you make a
little tiny salad and somehow this
atomized thing okay it's supposed to
mean something it's all to me very
superficial very cynical uh very distant
i like i i am i am the product okay of
old historicism the german philology i
decided my my first
choice of a profession when i was a
child would was egyptology archaeology
i'm everything i ever think about or say
is is related to an enormous time scheme
okay from from antiquity and indeed from
the stone age right and that is the
problem with with these people they're
they're male educated the postmodernist
and academic marxists okay are male
educated embarrassingly so okay they
know nothing before the present foucault
okay is absolutely a joke before the
enlightenment okay
perhaps he might be useful to people to
talk about what happened after
neoclassicism which by the way he failed
to notice okay all right a lot of what
he was talking about okay turns out to
see be simply the hangover of
neoclassicism okay this this is how
ignorant that man was i mean he was he
was not talented as a researcher he knew
absolutely nothing okay it was so you
know nothing about antiquity how can you
make any kind of large
structure a large mechanism you know to
analyze western culture without knowing
about classical antiquity okay he did
not see anything this was a person who
had no business making large theoretical
statements about anything well maybe
part of it is that
if you if you generate an intelligible
doctrine of radical relativism
then there is no reason to assume that
there are distinctions between
categories of knowledge or between
different levels of quality of knowledge
right so
i've seen the same thing in in the
psychology departments although we have
the uh what would you call it the luxury
of being bounded at least to some degree
by the empirical method and by biology
right it's one of the things that keeps
most of the branches of psychology
relatively sane you know because the
real world is actually built into it to
some degree
but
if you accept the post-modernist claim
of radical relativism then you
completely demolish the idea that there
are quality levels that are associated
with education because everything
becomes the same and that seems to me to
be a perfectly reasonable justification
for maintaining ignorance you know like
foucault i actually found him the most
readable of the la dereda foucault triad
you can read foucault i read madness and
civilization in a couple of his other
books and i thought they were painfully
obvious you know the idea that mental
disorder is in part a social construct
is self-evident to anybody who has even
a smattering of psychiatric training i
mean the the real narrow medical types
tend to to think of a
mental disorder let's say as something
that might be purely biological they
have a pure disease model but nobody's
who's a sophisticated thinker ever
thinks that it's a
partly because medicine is a brand of
engineering not a brand of science
because it's associated with health and
the diagnostic categories are hybrids
between physiological observation and
sociocultural condition everyone knows
that and so when i read madness and
civilization i thought well that's not
radical that's just bloody self-evident
but well you know foucault's admirers
actually think that he began you know
the entire turn towards the sociological
you know grounding of modern psychology
the social psychology was was well well
launched in the 1920s for example
the levels of ignorance these these
people who think foco are so original
have not read durkheim they've not read
marx weber they've not read irving
goffman okay so in other words
to me from everything in focusing
obviously because i had read the sources
from which he was borrowing without
attribution so i mean again i know these
people i mean i i've met in some cases
you know knew them in graduate school
people who went on to become these these
these admirers of foucault lecka and
derida and i know what their training
was their training was purely within the
english department that's all they ever
knew they never made any research
outside of that right and so the idea so
foucault is simply this ease a mechanism
it's like a little tiny kit by which
they can approach everything in culture
and then and then the but the
contortions of language the deliberate
labyrinthine elitist language at the
same time as pretending to be a leftist
okay this is one of the biggest frauds
ever practiced so i got a story to tell
you that you might like because i've
thought a lot about that use of language
you know because language can be used as
camouflage and so here's the story i
think i got this from robert sapolsky
so he was talking about zebras
and zebras of course have stripes and
hypothetically that's associated with
camouflage but it's it's not a
straightforward association because
zebras are black and white and they're
on the velt along with the lions the
lions are camouflaged because they're
grass-colored but the bloody zebras are
black and white you can see them like 15
miles away so okay so biologists go out
to study zebras and they're like making
notes on a zebra and they watch it then
they look down at their notes and then
they look up and they think oh
i don't know which zebra i was looking
at so the camouflage is actually against
the herd because a zebra is a herd
animal not an individual and so the
black and white stripes break up the
animal against the herd so you can't
identify it so this was a quandary for
the biologists so they did one of two
things one was drive a jeep up to the to
the zebra herd and use a dab of red
paint and dab the haunch of the zebra or
tag it with an ear tag like he used for
cattle
the lions would kill it
so as soon as it became identifiable
the predator yes
the predators could organize their hunt
around that identifiable animal that's
why you know there's the old idea that
lions and predators take down the weak
animals but they don't they take down
the identifiable animals so that's the
thing is if you stick your damn head up
you get picked off by the predators and
so one of the things that academics seem
to do is congregate together in
herd-like entities and then they share a
language right and the language unites
them and also keeps them as long as they
share the same set of linguistic tools
among themselves
they know that there isn't anybody in
the in the coterie that's going to
attack them or destabilize the entire
herd and that seems to me to account for
that impenetrable use of language it's
it's it's group protection strategy and
it has absolutely nothing to do with the
search for it's the search for security
within a system and not the desire to
expand the system
but to me it's blatantly careerist
because it was it was about advancement
and it was also about the claim that
somehow they have like special expertise
this is a special technical language no
one else can understand it only only
weekend but what's absurd about it
absolutely ludicrous all right that
these people these these american
academics are imitating the contorted
language of french translations from the
french okay
when la con is translated into into
english right there's a contortion there
okay what he's what he was trying to do
in french was to break up okay the
neo-classical formulations that
descended from racine there was
something that was going on there was a
sabotage of the french language going on
that was necessary in france not
necessary in english we we have this
long tradition of poetry going back to
shakespeare in chaucer we have we have
our own language far more vital than
that than the french oh yeah the french
can strain their language all the time
by beer
absolutely in amateurism okay of of
american academics okay trying to
imitate okay a a translation of la con
okay when le con's doing something in
france that is absolutely not necessary
and indeed wrong to be doing in english
right so the the at the the utter
cynical abandonment okay of the great
tradition of of you know of of the
english departments i and i i i felt
that the true radicalism was not about
adding on other departments okay so we
have african-american studies and you
know and and women's studies and so on
the true radicalism would have been to
shatter the departmental structure
that's what i wanted i feel that was the
authentic revolutionary 1960s thing to
do right to like to blend all the
literate literature studies you know
studies together okay
so to make easier to make an
interdisciplinary kind of organization
uh you know closer to the british model
where a person can pursue related
subjects overlapping subjects
these these departmental models okay are
were to me totalitarian to begin with
okay separating language into fiefdoms
and what what this did to create english
women's studies department absolutely
out of the air to snap your fingers and
create women's studies the english
department had taken a century to
develop okay it was a huge argument okay
within with within it right and all of a
sudden to create okay a department with
a politicized agenda from the start okay
by people without any training whatever
in that field what should be the what
should be the parameters of the field
what should be the requirements of that
field how about biology okay if you're
going to be discussing gender that
should have been a number one
requirement okay as part of any women's
studies department or program but no
okay it was all hands off it was just
the administrators wanted to solve a
public relations problem they had a
situation with very few women faculty uh
uh nationwide at a time when the women's
movement had just started up that
spotlight of attention was was on them
they want they needed women faculty fast
they needed the women's subject on the
agenda fast right so they just like poof
let there be women's studies okay and
now we'll just hire some women usually
from english departments you know here
here and there and we'll just throw them
together you invent it you say what it
is so that's why women's studies got
frozen at a certain point of ideology
okay of the early 1970s i was already in
revolt from it okay i was a precursor in
terms of my endorsement of feminism
before before even now was created right
but i couldn't i couldn't even have a
conversation with any of these women
they were hysterical about the subject
of biology they knew nothing about
hormones okay i mean i i probably got
fistfights over this they were people
were so convinced that biology had
nothing whatever to do with gender
differences right see that also seems to
me to be related to the post-modern
emphasis on power yeah because there's a
there's something terrible underground
going on there and that is and i i think
this is the sort of thing that was
reflected in the soviet union too in the
especially in the 20s when there was
this idea a radical idea that you could
remake human beings entirely right
because they had no essential nature
and so if your fundamental hypothesis is
that nothing exists except power and you
believe that then that also gives you
the right in some sense to exercise your
power at the creation of the kind of
humanity that your utopian vision
envisions and then that has no that and
that also seems to me to justify the
postmodern insistence that everything is
only a linguistic construct it again
goes down to the notion of power which
daredevil and foucault and lakau are so
bloody obsessed with and so and it seems
to me what they're trying to do is to to
take all the potential power for the
creation of human beings to themselves
without any bounding conditions
whatsoever right there's no history
there's no biology there's and and
everything is a fluid culture that can
be manipulated at will and so i mean in
canada there are terrible arguments
right now about biological essentialism
let's say and one of the things that
happened which was something i objected
to precisely a year ago is that the
social constructionist view of human
identity has been built now into
canadian law so there's an insistence
that
biological
sex
gender identity gender expression and
sexual proclivity vary independently
with no causal relationship between any
of the levels and so that's in the law
and not only is it in the law it's being
taught everywhere it's being taught in
the armed forces it's being taught in
the police it's being taught to the
elementary school kids and the junior
high school kids and underneath it all i
see this terrible striving for arbitrary
power that's associated with this crazy
utopianism and and and but i still don't
exactly understand it i don't like i
don't understand that what seems to be
the hatred that motivates it that you
see bubbling up for example in identity
politics and and in the desire to do
nothing but let's say demolish the
patriarchy it kind of reminds me and
this is something else i wanted to talk
to you about you know and you're you're
an admirer of eric neumann and of carl
jung yeah and that's the neumann
connection is really interesting because
i think he's a bloody genius i really
like the great mother is a great book
and really a great warning that book and
also the origins and history of
consciousness one of my most influential
books yeah that's so interesting i read
an essay that you wrote i i don't
remember when it was a lecture i gave on
neumann at the nyu yes yes it's always
been staggering to me that that book
hasn't had the impact that it should
have had i mean jung himself in the
preface to that book wrote that that was
the book that he wished that he would
have written it's very much associated
with young symbols of transformation and
it was a major influence on my book maps
of meaning which was an attempt to
outline the universal archetypes that
that are portrayed in the kind of
religious structures that you that you
put forward but the thing that i really
see happening and you can tell me what
you think about this in in neumann's
book
consciousness which is masculine
symbolically masculine for a variety of
reasons is is viewed as rising up
against the countervailing force of
tragedy from an underlying feminine
symbolically feminine unconsciousness
right and it's something that can always
be pulled back into that unconsciousness
that would be the microcosm of that
would be the freudian eatable mother
familial dynamic where the mother is so
over
uh protective and all-encompassing that
she interferes with the development of
the competence not only of her sons but
also of her daughters of her children in
general and it seems to me that that's
the dynamic that's being played out in
our society right now is that there's
this and it's it's related in some way
that i don't understand to this to this
insistence that all forms of masculine
authority are nothing but tyrannical
power so the symbolic representation is
tyrannical father with no appreciation
for the benevolent father and benevolent
mother with no appreciation whatsoever
for the tyrannical mother right and
that's that and because i thought of
ideologies as fragmentary mythologies
that's where they get their archetypal
and psychological power right and so in
a balanced representation you have the
terrible mother and the great mother as
neumann laid out so nicely and you have
the terrible father and the great father
so that's the fact that culture mangles
you half to death well it's also
promoting you and developing you you
have to see that as balanced and then
you have the heroic and adversarial
individual but in the postmodern world
and this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the
culture at large you have nothing but
the tyrannical father nothing but the
destructive force of masculine
consciousness and nothing but the
benevolent
benevolent great mother and it's a it's
an appalling ideology and it seems to me
that it's sucking the vitality
which is exactly what you would expect
symbolically it's sucking the vitality
of our culture you see that with the
increasing demolition of of young men
and not only young men in terms of their
academic performance which like they're
falling way behind in elementary school
way behind in junior high and bailing
out of the universities like mad
and so and i i well the public school
education has become completely
permeated by this kind of anti-male
propaganda i mean
to me public schools are just a form of
imprisonment you know right now they're
particularly destructive to young men
who have a lot of physical energy
now you know i identify as transgender
okay myself but i do not
i do not require the entire world to
alter itself okay to fit my particular
self-image i do believe in the power of
hormones i believe that men exist and
women exist and they are biologically
different i think that i think there is
no cure for
the culture's ills right now except if
men start standing up okay and demanding
that they be respected as men again okay
so i got a question about that so so one
of the things we did a research project
a year ago trying to figure out if there
was such a thing as political
correctness from a psychometric
perspective to find out if
the loose aggregation of beliefs
actually clumped together statistically
and we actually found two factors which
i won't go into but then we looked at
things that predicted adherence to that
that uh politically correct creed and
there were a couple that were surprising
one was being female was a predictor
the personality attributes associated
with femininity so that would be
agreeableness and higher levels of
negative emotion were also both
independent predictors but so were
symptoms of personality disorder which i
thought was really important because
part of what i see happening is that
like i think that women whose
relationship with men have has been
seriously pathologized cannot
distinguish between male authority and
competence and male tyrannical power
like they fail to differentiate because
all they see is the oppressive male and
and they may have had experiences that
that
their experiences with men might have
been rough enough so that that
differentiation never occurred because
it has to occur and you have to have a
lot of experience with men and good men
too before that will occur
but it seems to me that we're also
increasingly dominated by a view of
masculinity that's mostly characteristic
of women who have terrible personality
disorders and who are unable to have
healthy relationships with men now but
here's the problem you know
this is something my wife has pointed
out too she said well men are going to
have to stand up for themselves but
here's the problem i know how to stand
up to a man who's
who's uh unfairly
trespassing against me and the reason i
know that is because the parameters for
my resistance are quite well defined
which is
we talk we argue we push and then it
becomes physical
right like if we move beyond the
boundaries of civil discourse we know
what the next step is okay that's
forbidden in in discourse with women and
so i don't think that men can control
crazy women i don't think i really don't
believe it i think that they have to
throw their hands up in in in
in what in in it's not even disbelief
it's that the cultural there's no step
forward that you can take under those
circumstances
because if the man is offensive enough
and crazy enough the the reaction
becomes physical right away or at least
the threat is there and when men are
talking to each other in any serious
manner that underlying threat of
physicality is always there especially
if it's a real conversation and keeps
the thing civilized to some degree you
know if you're talking to a man who
wouldn't fight with you under any
circumstances whatsoever then you're
talking to someone to whom you have
absolutely no respect but i can't see
anyway for example there's a there's a
woman in in toronto who's been uh
organizing this movement let's say
against me and some other people who are
going to do a free speech
event and she managed to organize quite
effectively and she's quite um offensive
you might say she compared us to nazis
for example which you know publicly
using the swastika which wasn't really
something i was all that fond of but i
i'm defenseless against that kind of
female insanity because the
techniques that i would use against a
man who was employing those tactics are
forbidden to me so i don't know like it
seems to me that it isn't men that have
to stand up and say enough of this even
though that is what they should do it
seems to me that it's same women who
have to stand up against their crazy
sisters and say look enough of that
enough man-hating enough pathology
enough bringing disgrace on us as a as a
gender
but the problem there and then i'll stop
my little tirade is that most of the
women i know who are sane are busy doing
sane things right they're off they have
their career they have their family
they're quite occupied and they don't
seem to have the time or maybe even the
interest to go after their their crazy
harpy sisters and so i don't see any
regulating force for that that terrible
femininity and it seems to me to be
invading the culture and undermining the
the masculine power of the culture in a
way that's i think fatal i really do
believe that i i too i too believe that
these are there's a symptomatic of the
decline of western culture and we and it
will just go down flat i don't think
people realize that you know masculinity
still exists okay in the world as a code
among jihadists okay and when you have
passionate masculinity okay circling the
borders like the huns and the vandals
during the roman empire that's what i
see i see this culture rotting from
within okay and and disembowelling
itself literally now might have an
overview of why we're having these
problems right and it comes from the
fact that i'm the product of an
immigrant family all four of my
grandparents and my mother were born in
italy so i remember from my earliest
years in this factory town in upstate
new york where
my relatives came to work in the shoe
factory i can remember still okay the
the life of the agrarian era okay which
went out which was for most of human
history okay the agrarian era where
there was the world of men and the world
of women and the sexes had very little
to do with each other each had power and
status in its own realm right and they
and they laughed at each other in in
essence okay the women the women had
enormous power in fact the old women
ruled not the young beautiful woman like
today okay but the
the older you were the more you had
control over everyone including the
mating and marriage um
there were no doctors so the so you had
the you know the old women were like
midwives and knew all the ins and outs
of this inherited knowledge about
pregnancy and all these other things
right i can remember this this and the
joy that women had with each other all
day long okay cooking with each other
companions to each other talking
conversing my mother remembered as a
small child in italy when it was time to
do the laundry they would take the
laundry up the mount up the hill to the
fountain il sorgo okay and and do it by
hand they would sing they would picnic
and so on right and we get a glimpse of
that in the odyssey when odysseus is is
is thrown up naked on the shores of
feyeisha all right and and he hears the
sound of women
young women laughing and singing and
it's nausicaa the princess bringing the
women to do the laundry okay it's
exactly the same thing right so there
was a each each gender had its own
hierarchy its own values its own way of
talking and the sex is rarely
intersected like i can remember in my in
childhood on a holiday typical it could
be a christmas it could be a
thanksgiving whatever all every women
would be cooking all day long everyone
would sit down to eat okay and then
after that okay the women would retire
unmasked to the kitchen and the men
would go i would i would look at the
window and see all the men the men would
be all outside usually gather on the car
okay at a time when cars didn't work as
well as they do today with the hood up
okay and the men would be standing with
their hands and their hips like that
everyone's staring at the engine and i
went that's how i learned okay men were
refreshing themselves by studying
something technical and mechanical after
being with the women okay you know for
during the dinner okay so so all of
these problems of today are the direct
consequence of women's emancipation and
freedom from the housework thanks to
capitalism okay which made it possible
for women to have jobs outside the home
for the very first time in the 19th
century no longer to be dependent on a
husband or father or brother right and
so this great
great thing that's happened to us that
allowing us to be totally self and you
know self-supporting independent agents
has produced all this animosity about
between men and women because the women
women feel unhappy women today wherever
i go whether it's italy or brazil or
england or america okay or toronto okay
the the the upper middle class
professional women are unhappy miserable
they want and they don't know what why
they're unhappy they want to blame it on
men okay men must change men must become
more like women no that is the wrong way
to go okay it's when men are men okay
and understand themselves as men are
secure as men then you're going to be
happier yeah well there's nothing more
dangerous than a weak man yeah
absolutely okay especially all these
quizzlings okay spouting feminist
hear rumors
okay it makes me sick but here's the
point
men and women have never worked side by
side ever maybe on the farms okay when
you were like maybe one person's in the
potato field the other one's over here
in the tomato tomatoes or whatever okay
you you had you had families working
working side by side exhausted with each
other no time to have any clash of this
it was a collaborative effort on farms
and so on never in all of human history
have men and women been working side by
side and women are now the pressure
about silicon valley they're also sexist
oh they're saying they don't allow women
in and so on the men are being men in
silicon valley all right and those
especially the engineers and the women
are demanding that oh this is terrible
you're being said maybe the sexes okay
have their own particular form of
rhetoric their own particular form of
you know identity okay maybe okay we
need to re re examine okay this business
about you know
maybe we have to perhaps accept some
degree of tension and conflict between
the sexes okay it in a work environment
i don't mean harassment i'm talking i'm
talking about women feeling
disrespective to how somehow their with
their opinions when they express them
okay are not taken seriously or or that
or even hillary clinton is complaining
oh when a woman writes something online
she's attacked immediately and so well
everyone's attacked online what are you
talking about the world is tough the
world is competitive okay identity is
honed okay by conflict the idea that
there should be no conflict that we have
to be in this bath okay of approbation
yes and you know it which is just well
that's the devouring mother that's right
it's absolutely infantile i mean okay so
a couple of things there well the first
thing is is that
the agreeableness trait that divides men
and women most there's three things that
divide women and men most particularly
from the psychometric perspective one is
that women are more agreeable than men
and so that seems to be the primary
maternal dimension as far as i can tell
it's associated with
a desire to avoid conflict but it's it's
associated with interpersonal closeness
compassion politeness women are reliably
higher than men especially in the
scandinavian countries and and in the
countries where egalitarianism has
progressed the farthest so that's where
the difference is
maximize which is one of the things
james damore pointed out quite correctly
in his infamous google memo okay women
are higher in negative emotions so
that's anxiety and emotional pain that
that difference is approximately the
same size and again that maximizes in
egalitarian societies which is extremely
interesting and then the biggest
difference is the difference in interest
between people and things and so women
are more interested in people and men
are more interested in things which goes
along quite nicely with your car
anecdote
but
the thing about men interacting with men
again is that it isn't that they respect
each other's viewpoints that's not
exactly right what happens with a man
and i know a lot of men that i would
regard as as remarkably tough people for
for one reason or another and everything
you do with them is a form of combat
like if you want your viewpoint taken
seriously often you have to yell them
down and like they're not going to stop
talking unless you start talking over
them you know and it's it's not like men
are automatically giving respect to
other men because that just doesn't
happen it's that the combat is there and
it's expected and one of the problems
and so this is part of the reason why i
think men are bailing out of so much of
academia and and maybe the academic
world in general and maybe the world in
general is that men actually don't have
any idea how to compete with women
because the problem is is that if you
unleash yourself completely then you're
an absolute bully and there's no doubt
about that because
if men unleash themselves on other men
that can be pretty goddamn brutal
especially for the men that are really
tough and so that just doesn't happen
with women ever but so you can't unleash
yourself completely if you win you're a
bully if you lose well you're just
bloody pathetic so how the hell are you
supposed to play a game like that you
know so in i've worked with lots of
women in law firms in in in canada for
example and and high achieving women
like really remarkable people i would
say and they're often nonplussed i would
say by the attitude of the men in the
law firm because they would like to see
everyone pulling together because
they're all part of the same team
whereas the men are like at each other's
throats in in a cooperative way because
they want the law firm to succeed but
they want to be the person who's at the
top of the success hierarchy right so
and that that doesn't jive well with the
more competitive or cooperative ethos
that's part and parcel of agreeableness
and so
we don't really have any idea how to
integrate male and female dominance
exactly that's exactly right this is why
i love this show real housewives right
which which is gorgeous
and just just last night okay i was
watching one an episode right where the
women were at each other okay at a party
and all in in recounting but i said this
to you and but you said this to me and
yes and the men got we got together
there and said well this is the way they
communicate you know with each other and
you know in that you know men we we men
okay just we'll have a fist fight and
we'll and and ten minutes later we're
going to have a beer at the bar
next to each other and so and i i have
observed that in my entire my daughter
my daughter used to be really irritated
about that because she she like most
people
was the target of feminine uh
conspiratorial bullying at one she's no
push over my daughter so this wasn't
like this was a continual thing or that
she didn't know what to do about it but
she had to observe
these girls conspiring against her and
then blackening her name on on facebook
which is part of the part and parcel of
the typical female bullying routine
which is often reputation demolition
right that there's a good literature on
that and then she'd watch what would
happen if
my brother or my son would have a uh
dispute with his friends you know and
maybe they were drinking and there was a
dispute they'd have a fight and then the
next day they were friends again and
that's another thing that's strange is
that like men have a way of bringing a
conflict to a head and resolving it
right and that it isn't obvious to me
that women have that same
perhaps you might call it luxury but
it's also the case that men don't know
what to do when they get into a conflict
with a woman because what the hell are
you supposed to do you know mostly what
you're supposed to do is avoid it and
and
well i've seen um you know i don't know
whether this crosses into other
countries but that there's a certain
kind of taunting and teasing that men
boys do with each other that toughens
them okay and where they don't they
don't take things seriously but a girl's
feelings become extremely hurt if she
hears something that goes very tough you
know again like sarcastic against her so
i i mean i do feel that there are
profound differences between the sexes
in terms of emotions in terms of
communication patterns uh you know my
father used to say that he could never
follow women's conversations he said he
said women don't even finish their
finished sentences that the women
understand immediately what the other
woman is saying okay uh and
um in the way women tend to be more
interested or have have been
traditionally more interested in soap
operas it's not just that the women who
are home without jobs it's that i
honestly i believe that soap opera does
reflect does mirror the way women talk
to each other these communication
patterns have been built up through
women the world of women okay which
which was it made sense there was a
division of labor okay it wasn't sexism
against women that there was a division
of labor the men went off to hunt and
did the dangerous things the women
stayed around the hearth because you had
pregnant women nursing women older women
okay they were cooking and so on so i
feel that these communication patterns
that we're talking about have been built
up okay over the centuries and the men
had to toughen each other okay to go out
you know the hunting parties of native
americans you know it would they could
be gone for two weeks and when the
temperature was below zero many of them
died okay
the idea that somehow oh
any kind of separation of the sexes or
different spheres of the sexes is
inherently sexist and yeah and
inherently driven by empowered dynamics
the answer to all of this okay
everything that we're talking about okay
is education into early history okay and
until you until people understand the
stone age the nomadic period the
agrarian era and the and how culture how
civilization built up okay in
mesopotamia the great irrigation
projects
or in egypt okay where you had for the
first
centralized government authority became
necessary okay to master these these you
know we had a situation where an
environmentally uh
uh you know difficult situation like the
deserts of mesopotamia or or the the
peculiar character of of egyptian
geography where you can only have a
little tiny tiny fertile line along the
edges of the nile okay an otherwise
desert landscape so this civilization
and authority okay right it's not
necessarily about power grabbing but
about organization to achieve
something for the good of the people as
a whole you know yes
well that's exactly the symbolism the of
the great by reducing all hierarchy to
to power okay and and selfish power okay
is it is utterly naive it's ignorant
right so i i say education has to be
totally reconstituted including public
education to begin in the most distant
past so that so our young people today
who know nothing about how the how the
world was created that they inhabit okay
can understand okay what what marvelous
technological paradise they live in and
it's the product of capitalism the
product product of individual innovation
it's the product most of it's the
product of a western tradition that
everyone wants to trash now et cetera if
you begin in the past and show it also
talk about war
because with the war is the one thing
that wakes people up okay as we see
warriors as we may see
yes okay war is the reality principle my
father and all in five of my uncles went
to world war ii you know and you know my
father was was part of the the force
that landed in japan okay
uh you know he's a paratrooper um you
know at the time of the japanese
surrender okay and all you know and my
couple uncles got shot up and so on when
you have the reality of war when people
ex see the reality of the horrors of war
berlin burned
know to a crisp and so on your
starvation okay then you understand okay
there's a marvelous mechanism that
brings water you know to you to the to
the kitchen and when you flip on a light
and elect like the electric electricity
for me like and i suppose it's because i
have somewhat of a depressive
temperament i mean one thing that
staggers me on a consistent basis is the
fact that anything ever works i mean
because it's so unlikely you know to to
to be in a situation where our
electronic communications work where our
where our electric grid works and it
works all the time right it works a
hundred percent of the time and the
reason for that is that there are mostly
men out there who are breaking
themselves into pieces repairing this
thing which just falls apart all the
time absolutely i said this in the monk
debate okay in toronto several years ago
i said that this is the invisible all
these these these you know these
elitists you know professors sneering at
men it's men who are maintaining
everything around us okay this invisible
army okay which which feminists don't
notice right nothing would work or
regard regard as oppressive which is you
know like a professor is someone who's
standing on a hill surrounded by a wall
which is surrounded by another wall
which is surrounded by another wall like
it's walls all the way down who stands
up there and says i'm brave and
independent it's like you've got this
protected area that's so unlikely it's
so absolutely unlikely and the fact that
people aren't on their knees in
gratitude all the time for the fact that
we have central heating and air
conditioning and
pure water and reliable food it's just
it's
it is it's absolutely unbelievable
people used to die for the water supply
okay
it was contaminated with cholera for
heaven's sakes right people don't
understand okay they have clean water
fresh milk fresh orange juice all of
these things these are more and all of
the time all the time
and that western culture is heading okay
because we are so dependent on this on
this invisible infrastructure we're
heading for an absolute catastrophe when
the jihadists figure out how to paralyze
the power grid the entire culture will
be chaotic you'll have mobs in the
street okay know within three days okay
when suddenly the food supply is
interrupted and there's no like there's
no no way to communicate there'll be
like a robber i mean that that is the
way western culture is going to collapse
okay and it won't take much single
points of failure
because we are so interconnected and now
we are so it's so it's so dependent on
communications and computers
i've i used to predict for years there
will be an asteroid hitting there yeah
well do you have another another you
know how the solar flares work
so back in this happens about once every
century so back about 1880 and i don't
remember the exact year there was a
significant enough solar flare so that
produces an electromagnetic pulse like a
hydrogen bomb because the sun is a
hydrogen bomb an electromagnetic pulse
will emerge from the sun and wave across
the earth and it produces huge spikes in
electrical electrical current along
anything that's electronic and it'll
burn them out it let it lit telegraph
operators on fire in the 1800s and wow
one of those things took out the quebec
power grid in 1985 and knocked out the
whole northeast corridor and so they
figured those things are about one in a
century event but those single i have my
brother-in-law who's a very smart guy he
designed the chip and the iphone we were
talking about political issues the last
time i went and saw him in san francisco
and his notion was that all that the
government should be doing right now is
stress testing our infrastructure the
same way they stress test the banks
because we're so full of these single
points of failure that and i think
you're absolutely right luckily we've
been
what would you call
invaded by stupid terrorists instead of
smart terrorists because a smart
terrorist could do an unbelievable
amount of damage in a very short period
of time so and it's just god's good
graces that that hasn't happened yet
and so and then what will happen is that
it's the men okay the men will
reconstruct civilization while the women
cower in the houses and have the men go
out and do all the dirty work that's
what's going to happen again only men
will will bring civilization back again
so what okay so now a couple of things
so the the universities i mean i've
proposed although it's something that's
probably beyond my power that what
should happen is that the universities
the real content of the universities
should be stolen back from the
universities because they're not making
use of their intellectual property and
that something should be started online
that would constitute a genuine
university the problem is the
accreditation issue but i don't think
that's an unsolvable problem but do you
see
like all these people who have these
post-modern neo-marxist agendas are
completely embedded inside the
universities absolutely and and the
point is over over the last 25 years i
have received constant mail from people
dropping out of the graduate schools
right and or giving up altogether on any
idea of being a college professor so
what's happened is that the most
talented and independent thinking people
okay have avoided in the school so we
we're now who we have are the compliant
the servile okay the people who are
currently in the university and and
hiring their successors okay are
are male-educated themselves okay i mean
i i one of the first letters i received
in the early 1990s i'll never forget it
from a woman who was now painting houses
in missouri and said she had been part
of the comparative literature graduate
program at uh you know at berkeley and
that she finally had to drop out because
she said every time she would express
enthusiasm for what they were reading
the cl the people looked at her as if
she had somehow created an offense
another in other words enthusiasm for
art and the very things you need as a
teacher in the classroom okay we're
being
trained out okay yeah well the thing is
if you respect art and literature that
means that you implicitly accept a
hierarchy of quality right and that of
course contradicts the fundamental
tenets of the post-modern doctrine which
is that there are no hierarchies of
quality and you know you you talked a
little bit earlier about the the idea
that
you referred again to the idea that
everything is associated with power and
that's that's the thing that i can't
help but associate with with a kind of
personality pathology like you know from
a psychometric perspective the best
predictors of long-term success in our
society are intelligence iq
which you can measure very accurately
and trait conscientiousness which
actually is a real testament to the
culture right because what you'd hope is
that the smart people who work hard are
the people who advance not it isn't like
they deserve it exactly that isn't what
i mean it's that if the culture is
harnessing the productive power of
individuals properly then it should
differentially reward people who are
smart and conscientious because they're
going to do a bunch of really
interesting work for the rest of us and
that's very well established finding
it's it's as good as any finding in the
social sciences but despite that and
despite the fact that everything works
which is a goddamn miracle of sorts
there is this consistent story that we
live in a patriarchy that it's only
oppressive that it's done nothing but
oppressed women since the beginning of
time which is also something that just
boggles my mind you know like i know
that men have sacrificed for women and
children including their lives okay for
thousands of years you know yes there's
been brutality but the brutality is the
minority okay yes this this sick
portrayal of human history is nothing
but male oppression and female victim
image okay this is a way to to
permanently ensure the infantilization
of women yes absolutely yes well and you
know you can even make the case from a
purely logical perspective so so here's
an interesting here's an interesting
fact
so
most of the people who abused their
children
were abused as children
but most of the people who were abused
as children don't abuse their children
right so if you look at the population
of abusers they were all abused so you
can say abuse causes abuse but that's
that's not a good idea because you have
a specific sample there right it's not a
random sample what happens is that abuse
dampens out over the centuries it
doesn't propagate itself and that's
obvious because if there was if if the
hypothesis of essential male tyranny was
true it would spread exponentially
through the population in like three
generations and there wouldn't be an
exception at all and so what happens is
even when there is a tilt towards
tyranny let's say in the family or even
in the society that regresses back to
something that's far more benign very
very rapidly and you see this so
to me one of the biggest unexamined
issues is the transition from the great
extended family of old okay into the
nuclear family okay so i i and i do feel
that freud is the best analyst of the
particular kind of claustrophobic cell
of of the modern nuclear family
it could be that human being it could be
that human beings were never intended
okay to be to be trapped in a house just
with their parents they extended
families you had your aunts and and you
know and grandparents and and and
cousins
all of whom helped form your identity
okay so what one had one's identity was
was a member of a community rather than
in this like hot house environment so i
think a lot of current issues including
um this sudden spate of transgender
claims and so on that a lot of these
things are coming from um this unstable
in in cell it's really a prison cell
of the nuclear family two parents
perhaps cannot give all the knowledge of
life okay to to to the young and so i i
think there are all kinds of of um
sexual issues you know in it that are
generated by it but with the uh you know
psychology today um is uh is now
simply a mat
a practical matter people come in uh you
know the psychologist in the united
states deals with your your present
problem let's not go into the distant
past okay let's just deal with our
present problem which are which
obviously we have forms of communication
we need to like fix this and then you'll
be fine okay as a consequence there's a
complete absence of any kind of analysis
of your experiences as a child with your
parents you know with you with your
siblings and so on how that might relate
to your current sexual identity issues
whether it's transgender or whether it's
homosexuality it is impos you could not
possibly ask okay about any genesis of
homosexuality today okay because that is
automatically defined as homophobic well
excuse me every single as an openly gay
you know the person myself every gay
person i know okay there is some story
there okay it seems to be in childhood
not only that there's a strange sim you
know similarity of the storylines of all
of my friends who are gay there's the
same pattern that had to do with blurred
borderlines
between a son and his mother and so on
i'm not blaming the mother okay i'm not
blaming the mother at all okay what i i
see is a dynamic going on in the
bourgeois house in the nuclear family
where you had sometimes a distant father
okay a father who was present but but
not not really engaged and a mother who
who who
made the son her companion in some way
often the mother has great imagination
and flair and they had a shared thing
and i mean the idea that homosexuality
has nothing whatever to do okay with
your family life is nonsense well it's
also completely well that's another
thing and i got a lot of trouble in
canada for my opposition to bill c-16
which was a bill that had to do with
transgender rights and i didn't really
give a damn about the transgender right
issue that had nothing to do with it
what bothered me was that there was an
issue of compelled speech because you
were required by the ontario human
rights commission to use the pronouns
that of the person's choice right
otherwise that's absolutely orwellian
that is that's right
that is absolutely intolerable you know
i i have said i said years ago okay that
my book sexual persona which was like a
700 page book i said that is the biggest
sex change in history because i okay
with my transgender issues all right
look to the magnificent
construction of english okay it was the
english language okay that i seized on
to gain my identity and my power as a
person right and therefore any intrusion
into english someone trying to tell me
how to use english this great gift okay
to me this is absolutely obscene and
evil okay for any government to try to
dictate to us how we're going to use
this magnificent instrument of english
yes absolutely and i that was for me the
breaking point because i believed well
and i think that that's associated with
the idea of the logos in the west you
know because that's a deep mythological
idea that the logos is the thing that
brings order out of chaos through
communicative speech and that that's
tightly aligned with your soul and i
don't care if you're an atheist or a
believer it doesn't matter it's still
the right language and that no one has
any right whatsoever under any
circumstances to trespass against that
and so but that's okay because that's
law in canada now and so but okay so now
back to your let's see you were making a
point about
it
yeah i knew we would agree oh yes okay
because it's it's interesting to look at
these things from obviously from
multiple perspectives which is another
thing ideologues don't do right because
for them everything is one cause there's
one that's how you can tell when you're
dealing with someone who's ideologically
possessed is they make everything
attributable to a single cause like
power so but so one of the things that's
happened with the nuclear family that's
quite interesting too is that
parents are older
and they and they have fewer children so
you could imagine that that hot house
environment in some sense has been
exaggerated for a bunch of reasons one
is
well your child is a lot more valuable
to you if you're older and you only have
one or two right because you're not
going to get another chance that first
of all you might have had some trouble
having the child to begin with
and you're not going to get another
chance so you've got all your eggs are
in one basket so to speak and then of
course children don't have the number of
siblings they used to have
and one of the things that's really
useful about having siblings is that
they keep you in your place right they
they're primary socialization agents and
i mean that can be brutal
and that's reflected say in the story of
cain and abel you know that that
internal household dynamic with siblings
can be can really become murderous and
that has to be kept under control but i
think the
the hot house flower person who's who's
incapable of tolerating any jibes or any
or any testing any dominance hierarchy
testing of the sort that you said that
men do part of that's the consequence of
being raised by older parents who have
excess resources who have no siblings
because the child is then of course
special and that's specialness well
there seems to be an inverse
relationship between that specialness
that's protected and the person's
robustness and resilience and so and
then that's caught into or not caught
into that's that's uh
uh pandered to by the universities which
insist upon setting up a situation where
no one is ever offended by anything
any of the time and that's something i
also can't understand at all because let
me just say that's a huge point you just
made okay because it's the upper middle
class of the
professional class okay who postpones
having the children okay because they go
to law school they go to medical school
right and and they and they have the
children after they're they're settled
okay in in a job okay so
they're the ones okay who have injected
this this this hyper-sensitive bourgeois
idea you know code in into the
universities now my my parents were 20
when they married and 21 when they had
me okay my father was a um you know uh
went to college on the gi bill getting
out of out of world war ii so
when i was born my father was still in
college and was sweeping
the floors and so on i am the product of
young parents and nature wants actually
younger parents right because because
pregnancy is is is quicker it's safer
okay and so on and my parents had the
energy okay to um you know this useful
energy that can do spirit that came out
of world war ii and so on i'm proud of
that then
then my only other sibling was born 14
years later okay my father at this point
was a college professor okay all right
so she had completely different parents
than than i did so she has very
excellent manners and so on she's
completely different okay right and i i
have all this like woman the energy
my parents were just a lot of their
teens okay so now today we have this
situation no and it's considered heresy
to raise this issue okay that you have
have young women are told okay there's
one future for you you are a future
leader okay you must you must move
forward okay four years of college and
then perhaps it's a professional class
all right so
maybe the women young women's bodies are
signaling okay that they want to be
mothers maybe maybe there are signals
coming from the body right of maybe now
wanting this this this this system of
education that was devised for men okay
that's being
funneled along channel along in this
mechanism all right so young women you
know feel unhappy they don't know why
they feel they they have no sense of
identity if they if they if they want to
marry and drop out of college right and
have have a baby they will be treated as
traitors to their class what you are a
future leader what have a baby only
working class women would do that okay
now i find working-class women okay in
general okay far more rounded as
personalities okay they express
themselves forcefully they have body
language that takes up space okay a man
says something to them on the street
they're right back in their face and so
on it's the bourgeois girls okay who are
taught that they're they're special okay
who have to postpone actual life okay
from for all these years they see these
these are the girls who are who
misjudged the fraternity parties setting
these are the girls who like run for
parental protection and hand holding on
on the committee investigating what went
wrong on their date and so on and so
forth so you so yes i i think that you
that you have located that's very
interesting the idea that these these
young girls okay who are so sensitive
okay in college so unable to handle
their sex life are the product of older
parents because they went through the
professional career track right yes and
they are they have not had the you know
the experience of the you know
competitiveness you know within them and
and teasing of other siblings and they
don't know how to do that well also you
know the thing about young parents is
they don't care as much as older parents
and that actually turns out to be better
because
what you really want for your children
is minimum necessary intervention right
and the developmental literature is
actually quite clear on this so if
you're at home with your child what the
best role that you can play is to be
there but not to be interacting with the
child all the time the child should be
off doing whatever it is the children do
which generally is playing with other
children right without it being mediated
also by screens and and technology
because that's how they formulate their
identity and that's how they learn to
play joint games with other people and
the parent is supposed to be there as a
recourse for the child when they go out
a little bit farther than they can
tolerate and they have to come back and
get some security and so but that isn't
that's especially not what happens to
single children because they're
basically raised as miniature adults so
and i wonder too like how much of the
antipathy towards these are dark musings
and i would say how much of the
antipathy towards men that's being
generated by say college age women is a
deep repugnance for the role that
they've been designed and a
disappointment with the men for who you
know like you think of those is it
carpathian um or or
um
i can't remember the culture
the the basic marital routine was to
ride into the village and grab the bride
and run away with her on a horse right
it's like the like the motorcycle gang
member who rips the two naive woman out
of girl out of the bosom of her family
and women it's like ancient myth yeah
there used to be bride stealing it was
quite it was quite quite widespread
right well so i kind of wonder if part
of the reason that modern university
aged women aren't so aren't so angry is
because that fundamental feminine role
is actually being denied to them and
they're they're objecting to that at a
really really fundamental level like a
level of primitive outrage at well
because what's happened is the chaos
that my generation of 1960s bequeathed
through the sexual revolution i went
when i arrived in college in 1964 okay
the colleges were still acting in local
parents in place of the parent so my
dormitory um
all women's dormitory uh we women had to
sign in at 11 o'clock at night the men
could run free the entire night so it
was my generation of women that rose up
and said give us the same freedom as men
have and the colleges replied no
the world is dangerous you could be
raped we have to protect you against
rape and what we said okay was give us
the freedom to risk rape okay so that
what that today's women don't understand
it's a freedom that you want is the same
freedom that gay men have when they go
and they pick up a stranger someplace
they know it's dangerous they know they
could end up beaten up or killed okay
but they find it hot if you want freedom
if you want equality okay then you have
to start behaving like a man
so what we did is is we we gave freedom
him to these young women for several
generations but my generation had been
raised in a far more resilient and
robust culture okay we had the strength
okay to
know what we wanted and to fight for
what we wanted these young women have
been raised in this protective terribly
protected ways right so i think in some
strange you know um fashion that that
all these demands for intrusion from
these you know stalinists
committees sexual you know investigating
dates and so on it's a way to
reinstitute okay the rules that my
generation threw out the window so i
think these young women are desperate
not only that but i have spoken out
very strongly in you know in a in a
piece i wrote for time magazine as in my
most recent book that the raising the
drinking age in this country okay from
18 to 21 okay has had a direct result
okay in these in these disasters of
binge drinking fraternity parties
because it to let college students the
way we could go out at as freshmen have
a beer
sit in a protected adult environment
learn how to discourse with the opposite
sex in in in in a safe you know
environment right and so on and you and
and now today okay because because of
the stupid rule that young people can't
even buy a drink okay you know in a bar
until they're 21 we have these the
fraternity parties that are that are
like it's a caveman era well of course
in in this modern age this is
disadvantages men okay men want to hook
up men want to have sex women don't
understand what men want you know women
women are like put out because they're
hoping that maybe the man will continue
to be interested in them okay the man
just wants experience okay that the
hormones drive toward
to me i've i've theorized okay that the
you know that the sex drive in men is
intertwined with with haunted pursuit
okay yes yes
i feel absolutely this is what women
don't understand okay
and if women understood what i
understand from my transgender
perspective all right
these women on the streets okay um you
know you know i'm obviously you know
madonna you know admirer and you know
and i i support pornography and
prostitution so i don't want what i'm
it's about to say to seem conservative
isn't it it isn't okay what i'm saying
is the women on the street young women
okay who are about who are jogging okay
with no bra on okay short shorts and
have and have earbuds in their ears okay
just jogging along like as i said these
women do not understand the nature of
the human mind they do not understand
the nature of psychosis okay and this
intertwining i'm talking about okay of
the hunt the hunting pursuit thing okay
they're triggering a hunt thing just
what what what you what um uh you have
talked about in terms of the zebra herd
okay they are triggering the hunt okay
uh impulse okay in psychotic men okay
they have here there goes a very
appetizing and and and totally oblivious
animal okay bouncing along here okay and
we're in a period now where psychosis is
not understood at all okay
young women have
had no exposure to movies like psycho
okay
the the you know the kind of uh the
rapist serial murderer thing and so on
the kind of strange dynamic that has to
do with it with the assault on the on
the mother imago you know in in the in
the mind of the psychotic so i think
this is an incredible naivete these
young women are emerging and going to
college and in in this like incredible
dinician environment of you know of a
sec orgy astic sexual experience in
fraternity houses they're completely
unprepared for it right and and so
you're getting all this outrage so
feminist rhetoric has gotten more and
more extreme in its portrayal of men as
evil but in fact okay what we have is a
cast it's a it's a chaos in the sexual
realm
the girls have not been told anything
real again
in terms of biological substratum to
sexually no and there's full of lies
about what constitutes consent too
exactly and it's become something that's
essentially portrayed linguistically as
a sequence of progressive contracts
which you know is it's well i think you
know i've thought for a while that we're
living in the delusional fantasy of a
naive 13 year old girl that's basically
sums up our culture and i look at all
these sexual rules that permeate the the
the academia and i think two things the
first thing i think is well
i know because i was an alcohol
researcher for a long time and you know
that 50 percent of violent crimes are
directly attributable to alcohol so if
you're murdered there's about a 50
chance that you're drunk and about a 50
chance that the person who kills you is
drunk and alcohol is the only drug that
we know that actually amplifies
aggression it does that in laboratory
situations plus it's a great
disinhibitor right so what alcohol does
is it it doesn't make you oblivious to
the future consequences of your action
because if you ask someone who's drunk
about the consequences of something
stupid they can tell you what the
consequences are but it makes you not
care and it does that because it's
technically an anxiolytic like like like
barbiturates or like benzodiazepines and
it also has a as a an activating um uh
property for many people who drink so
it's it's a stimulant and uh and an
anxiolytic at the same time and have
been a very very potent it's very potent
for both of them and you know we put
young people together and douse them in
alcohol right at the binge drinking
level and then which also interferes
with memory consolidation which of
course makes things much more complex
and then we're surprised when there are
sexual misadventures and you know and
then it's also attributed almost purely
to the predatory element that's that's
uh part and parcel of masculinity but a
tremendous amount of that is also
naivety and stupidity you know because
we expect like
18 18 year old guys especially the ones
that aren't that haven't been successful
with girls which is like 85 percent of
them because the successful men are a
very small percentage of men
the 85 percent who haven't been
successful with men or with women they
don't know what the hell they're doing
at all right and part of the reason
they're getting drunk is to
garner up enough courage to actually
make an advance you know and because i
think another thing that women don't
understand especially with regards to
young men is just exactly how petrifying
uh attractive woman who's of say
somewhat higher status actually is to a
young guy and there's lots of guys that
write me constantly and people that i've
worked with that are so terrified of
women they can't even talk to them it's
very very common well you know i take a
very
firm position which is that i want
college administrations to stay totally
out of the social lives of the students
right if a crime is committed it should
be reported to the police i've been
writing that for 24 25 years now right
but but it's not the business of any
college administration to take any
notice okay of what the students say to
each other say to each other as well as
do with each other okay i want it to
totally stop is fascism of the worst i
agree well it's it's i think it's
fascism of the worst kind because it's
an it's a new kind of fascism you know
it's it's partly generated by
legislation so like the title ix memo
that was written in 2011 i recently got
a copy of that goddamn thing that was
one polluting bit of legislation that
was that memo basically told
universities that unless they set up a
parallel court system they were going to
be denied federal funding
it is absolutely unbelievable incredible
and in in the the leftists are
supporting this i know i know
and this this shows there is no
authentic campus leftism i'm sorry it's
a fraud okay i mean you think
the faculty should be fighting the
administrations on this yeah
federal regulation of you know how we're
supposed to behave on campus well how
can you be so how can you be so naive
and foolish
to think that taking an organization
like the university which already has
plenty to do
and
forcing it to become a pseudo-legal
system that parallels the legal system
could possibly be anything but utterly
catastrophic it would mean you have to
know absolutely nothing about the legal
system and about the tremendous period
of evolution that produced what's
actually a stellar system and an
adversarial system that protects the
rights of the accused and of the and of
the victim and to replace that with an
ad hoc bureaucracy that has pretty much
essentially the same degree of power as
the court system with absolutely none of
the training and none of the guarantees
and the figure of courts there are
kangaroos that piece that i wrote about
date rape it was in uh january 1991 uh
newsday got the most controversial thing
i ever wrote in my entire career i
attacked the entire thing and demanded
the colleges stand back and get out of
the social lives of the students so on
and and people
the reaction people tried to recall they
called the president of my university
tried to get me fired you can't believe
the hysteria okay right i can believe it
yeah it yeah it well yes you could i
can't believe you can't believe it right
yeah yeah i think anything that where
anything that says to women okay that
they should be responsible for their own
choices is regarded as reactionary are
they kidding me okay this is such a
betrayal of authentic feminism in my
view
well it's the ultimate betrayal of
authentic feminism because it's it it's
an invitation of all the things that you
might be paranoid about with regards to
the patriarchy back into your life right
it's an insistence that the most
intrusive part of the tyrannical king
come and take control over the most
intimate details of your life incredible
absolutely incredible and the the
assumption is that that's going to make
your life better rather than worse right
and not to mention this idea of you know
this the stages of verbal consent as if
as if your impulses based in the body
have anything to do with words and so on
i mean that's the whole point is you
know about sex okay it's too abandoned
okay that you know that they're part of
the brain that's so that you know and
and trammelled with words i mean there's
you see this it's actually a marker of
of lack of social ability to have to do
that because if you're sophisticated
it's not like if you're dancing with
someone it's not like you call out the
moves right if you have to do that well
then you're you're you're more worse
than a nail fight right you're an
awkward neophyte and anybody with any
sense should get the hell away from you
and so if you're reduced to the point
where you have to verbally negotiate
every element of of intimate interaction
then what a downer well that yes but
what a what an unbelievably what would
you call it naive and pathological view
of the manner in which human beings
interact there's no sophistication in
that well what i'm worried about also in
this age of social media uh i've noticed
as a teacher in the classroom that the
young people are so used to
communicating now by cell phone okay by
iphone
um that they're losing body language and
facial expressions okay which i think is
going to compound the problem uh with
these dating uh encounters okay because
the ability to read the the human face
and into into into read little tiny
inflections of emotion
well i think my generation got that from
looking at great foreign films with
their with their long takes okay so
you'd have jean morrow and catherine de
nirov okay in like potential romantic
encounters and you could just see the
tiniest little little inflections right
they
that that signal communication or sexual
readiness or or irony or skepticism or
distance or whatever okay so the
inability to read
other people's intentions right that i
think this is going to be a disaster i
mean i i just noticed that um
how year by year okay the students are
are becoming much more flat affect okay
and they themselves complain that
they'll sit in the same room with
someone and and and be texting to each
other okay yeah yeah well there's a
there's a piece of evidence too that
supports that to some degree so women
with brothers are less likely to get
raped
and the reason for that is that they've
learned that non-verbal language deeply
right and they can they can they can
spot the not only that okay but i have i
have noticed okay uh in my into my
career okay that that women who have
many brothers okay
are very good okay as in administrators
and as business people okay all right
because they don't take men seriously
okay they regard
they they they saw their brothers they
think their brothers are jokes okay but
they know how to control men okay while
while they still like men okay they
admire men right so this is something
that i have seen you know repeatedly
yeah well so that would be also
reflective of the problem of fewer and
fewer siblings yes that's right okay
yeah yeah in in life i've noticed this
in publishing okay that's that the um
the the women who have this the job of
publicist okay and rise to the top as as
manager of publicity okay their ability
to take charge of men and and and
they're humorous men they they and
they have great relationships with men
okay because they don't have the sense
of resentment in in in worry and anxiety
and so they don't see men as aggressors
okay right and i think that's another
thing too is that as feminism um you
know moved into its present
system of ideology okay it has tended to
uh denigrate motherhood okay as a lesser
order of human experience and and to
enshrine of course abortion now i am 100
of abortion rights i mean i belonged to
planned parenthood for years until i
finally rejected it as a branch of the
democratic party my own party and so on
um but but as motherhood became excluded
as as feminism became obsessed okay with
the with with the work with the
professional woman okay i feel that the
lessons that that mothers learn have
been lost okay you know to to to to
feminism okay which is okay that if they
if if the mothers who who bear boy
children okay understand the fragility
of men the fragility of boys they
understand it they don't they don't see
men boys and men as a menace they
understand the greater strength of women
okay so there's this tenderness you know
and connectedness between the between
the mother and and the boy child okay
when motherhood is part of the
experience okay of of women who are
discussing gender so so what we have
today is that this this gender ideology
has risen up on campuses where we're all
none of the none of the girls none of
the students have married none of them
have had children okay and you have you
have women some of whom have had
children but a lot of them are lesbians
or like or like are you are like
professional women and so on okay so
this the whole tenderness and forgiven
forgiveness okay and encouragement that
women do to to boys okay they're fragile
they don't understand this
hypersensitivity of boys is not
understood okay instead boys are seen as
somehow
more privileged okay and somehow you
know
their their their energy level is is
interpreted as aggression okay potential
violence and so on okay right uh so i i
think that that
that what we would do better okay if we
would have i i have proposed okay that
colleges should allow uh when the moment
a woman is entered okay she has entrance
to that college for life okay and that
she that she should be free to to leave
okay to have babies when she when her
body wants that babies when it's healthy
to have them okay and then return have
haven't had the occasional course again
build up credits and fathers i mean you
might be able to do it as well and so on
to get married women women with children
into the classroom the moment that
happens it has happened after world war
ii okay we've had a lot of married guys
in the classroom and so on not yet not
that many women the experience of a
married person with a family okay
talking about gender but most of the
gender stuff would be left out of the
room okay if you had a real mother in
there who had experienced your child
birth and had had rate and it was
raising boys and so on so i think that's
that's also uh you know something that
uh has led to this this this incredible
you know artificiality and uh and
hysteria okay of feminist rhetoric
there's a there's another strange
element to that which is that on the one
hand the the radical feminist types the
neo-marxist post-modernists are are very
much opposed to the patriarchy let's say
and that's that unidimensional
ideological representation that has
never existed i mean perhaps the word
can be applied to republican rome and
that's it okay well and maybe it could
be applied usefully to certain kinds of
tyranny but not to a society that's
actually functional victorian england
one arguably okay but other than that to
use the word patriarchy in that in a
slap dash way so amateurist absolutely
absolutely you know it just shows people
know nothing about history whatever have
havre have done no reading so and so
what confuses me about that is that
despite the fact that the patriarch is
viewed as this essentially evil entity
and that that's associated with the
masculine energy that built this
oppressive structure
the antithesis of that which would
actually be femininity as far as i can
tell which is tightly associated with
care and with child rearing is also
denigrated so it's like the only proper
role for women to adopt is a patriarchal
role despite the fact that the
patriarchy is something that's entirely
corrupt so the hypothesis seems to be
that the patriarchy would be just fine
if women ran it
so no changes it's just that it would
just be a transformation of leadership
and somehow that would that would
rectify the fundamental problem even
though it's hypothetically supposed to
be structural okay so i'm going to close
with something
so
you know
there are elements in my character that
are optimistic you know i've i've looked
for example i worked for a u.n committee
and and on the relationship between
economic development sustainability and
i found out a variety of things that
were very optimistic like the fact that
you know the un set out to have poverty
between 2000 and 2015 worldwide and
actually hit that by about 2010 right so
we're in the period of the fastest
transformation of the bottom strata of
the world's population into something
approximating middle class that's ever
occurred and there's all these great
technological innovations on the horizon
and and it looks to me like things could
go extraordinarily well if we were
careful but i'm not optimistic and maybe
that's me i'm pessimistic because i also
see that there's five or six things
happening all of which appear at the
level of catastrophe that are all
happening at the same time and so one of
the things that i'd like to ask you is
like
what do you see happening in the next 10
years in in the universities or in
culture at large and i mean you just put
forward a proposal for the universities
for the treatment of women which i think
is very interesting one because women do
have a different time frame than men but
like
what the hell is the proper way forward
i've been encouraging young men to tell
the truth and to take responsibility and
there's a huge market for that message
but but i'm not convinced by any stretch
of the imagination that it's enough
what like when you look forward and you
try to be optimistic what the hell do
you see
well in in the largest you know scale um
i'm concerned about the future
of western culture because uh as a
student of history it looks too much to
me like ancient rome okay which became
overexpanded uh which became it was at
the mercy of a bureaucratic um
um the creep okay
and uh i can imagine one of them
right and the in the and roman identity
eventually um got blurred okay in in its
incorporation of so many different
cultures which at first seemed like a
healthy kind of multiculturalism but
eventually over expanding simply
collapsed of its own way so i i and i so
i am concerned about the you know
whether western culture is in a rapid
decline i think it would be very easy
because we are you know so
interconnected and so over complex very
easy you know to bring it to to ruin it
it would only take one major natural
disaster to do that but the universities
themselves i mean i think people are all
of a sudden in the united states much
more um attentive to issues of political
correctness because of the the riots at
berkeley which was the you know which
was the capital free speech i mean that
i mean the free speech movement happened
in the the spring uh before i entered
college in 1964.
one of the great principles and and
inspirational stories in my entire life
mario savio's you know uh you know
assertion of of the of the supremacy of
you know free thought and free speech
these are okay and i uh so i i think
that perhaps you know we we might just
have turned a corner and but it's going
to take a very very long time for the
university to be reformed i feel okay
that the cafeteria menu okay of of the
university curriculum has to be
abandoned we must return to historical
uh courses that begin in eight in the
earliest period in the stone age in
antiquity in order to give perspective
you know to to our to our president to
an analysis of our present culture i
want um uh 50 50 to 75 percent of
college administrators fired okay and
the money be transferred over okay to um
to to faculty into libraries into into
instruction okay um i i think that um
you know that obviously the the the way
things are being people are being
trained right now including at the
public school level okay is i i think i
think the public school level has gone
to hell you know when when when my
mother came you know came to united
states at the age of six the the with
the old public school system was still
very strict and therefore and she had um
excellent in education you know it's a
and um you know got all a's in in her in
her even though she started out not
speaking english spoke without an accent
et cetera okay so
so today this this kind of feel good
public school education uh which is
which is a form of ideology in
indoctrination right now it's all about
no bullying okay and so on and not about
anything and not even seriously about no
bullying
yes yeah so i mean i can tell in my own
students i mean i've been teaching for
46 years so i can tell this slow
degradation of public school education
okay to the point now that the students
have absolutely no sense of world
geography of world history okay they
know absolutely not they they don't know
anything about wars okay
and the reality the the the barbaric
reality of most of human history okay
and what it whatever that's triggering
yeah like right what a fantastic culture
we live in and so on now identity
politics itself has just got to stop i
mean it was important once okay and i i
was a rebel against the wasp you know um
hegemony okay white anglo-saxon
protestant germany in american culture
it was it was suffocating i i was raised
in the 1950s right when wasps controlled
corporations and and and education and
politics and so on and so the identity
politics was necessary once okay
we asserted gay rights okay he was in
stonewall rebellion of 1969. we are so
we asserted okay the women's rights with
the with with the rebirth of second wave
feminism in the late 1960s okay but this
endless okay preoccupation with a
fragmented identity we must return to
the authentic 1960s vision which is
about identity coming from consciousness
which transcends gender which transcends
all these divisions of race okay and
ethnicity okay consciousness itself okay
right
there's no sense of that any longer
that's what the 1960s saw well i see
that as a complete abandonment of
personal responsibility because that
like that consciousness i think
symbolically and i got a lot of this
from jung and also from eric neumann i
mean that's the great logos of the west
right that's the transcendent principle
which is is respect for the primacy of
individual consciousness and what goes
along with that primarily isn't
individual rights although that's built
into it i mean that's the reason we have
individual rights is for respect for
that but the responsibility that comes
along with being an individual instead
of the member of some group especially a
victimized group which is like a sure i
wrote an article with one of my students
who had toured the mass grave sites in
in the former yugoslavia you know and
had been exposed to that sort of thing
and
one of the things that our research
indicated was that the best predictor of
genocide is uh victimization on the part
of the group that produces the genocide
right a sense of an accelerated sense of
victimization and then it's well we get
them before they get us
so when everyone's being taught now that
they're a victim and then no one seems
to have any sense that you know that's
part of the essential tragedy of being
that life is suffering and that
and that and that and and that the world
rests on a foundation of suffering it's
nothing to take personally
and something to take responsibility for
instead of blaming and and resentment
and all of the things that have polluted
our universities and our culture well
and then there also was the abandonments
okay of the um you know of of of the
cannon okay the people you know asserted
that the cannon was the product of bias
and again of you know of a of a you know
provincial elitism and so on but in
point of fact as a student of the
history of the arts okay i can i can
assure people that the canon okay
overwhelmingly so is is the result of
what artists have determined okay we we
we
we say
a work is important as canonical because
art is following it okay we're
influenced by it we have this like
beautiful cascading tradition of
influence all right so that that's so
it's not but not another part of the
philistinism okay of of current
education to to you know to believe that
there are these external reasons okay
for for why a work lasts why a work you
know written 500 years ago or a thousand
years ago has a global relevance as if
it's some sort of political conspiracy
that's based on power as if anybody
could even manage that no matter how
nefarious they were right
but also you know
we you know we in the 60s we had had the
idea okay that there was like this a
human human sensibility okay that
transcendent individual
nations and and so on right and that and
that
there was this like rubric you know
cosmic consciousness okay
this this sense of the universe as a
whole and to see the human being in
relationship to great eternal principles
of you know life into death mortality
and so on uh whereas you know marxism is
blind marxism is very narrow all it sees
is a society okay it sees nothing beyond
society it doesn't seem nature okay i
mean it's absolutely mad okay how you
can have a system being taught okay in
universities right which which thinks
that this tiny thing of society okay
compared to the enormity and beauty of
of nature okay
it should take all of our uh you know
all of our you know absorb all of our
energy and attention so i mean i just
think that there's like a parochialism a
provincialism uh you know it it and now
all kinds of um you know
systematized elitism in our current
education has got to be rooted out and
we i want to return to basics great
simplicities and
all these faculty members teaching their
little tiny courses that have has to do
with their own specialty that's got to
stop okay people people can pursue
whatever they want in their private
research as scholars okay certainly
that's necessary but they must teach in
the core curriculum right
and and people must decide what is
crucial for an educated person to know i
do want a multicultural i do want a
global curriculum okay i want i want all
the cultures taught okay right
this is not the answer
marxism this neo-marxism in the
universities okay is simply it's lazy
it's a lazy way to assert
multiculturalism without actually doing
the research and the study of other
cultures
okay all right that's a good one to
close on we agreed on everything i knew
this
i knew it all right great thank you very
much